imagine your future
imagine our future
imagine the future of europe
over the coming months the conference on
the future of europe is your
chance to share ideas on what that
future will look like
27 countries nine themes one goal
to give you the power to shape our
future
from climate change to migration
democracy to the digital transition
it's the biggest ever consultation of
its kind
come and share your ideas on the
multilingual digital platform
and debate with other europeans take
part in one of hundreds of events in
person
or online or why not organize your own
grassroots event
in your community your ideas
submitted on the platform and formulated
at events will be examined by citizens
panels
before being presented to and discussed
by your representatives
the conference's executive board will
then present the results to the three eu
institutions which will use them to make
concrete eu policy proposals
policy based on the hopes and ideas of
europeans
visit futureeu.europa.eu
and get started today